for 20 years I'd worked to realize my
dream things don't happen overnight
Alena be a rebel make sure you win it'll
be revolutionary and fight what you
truly believe in success which you want
to speak about is born out of arrogance
people thinking they're good but
greatness comes from humility he's a
British chef restaurateur and television
personality
he has been dubbed the first celebrity
chef he was at the time the youngest
chef to receive three Michelin stars
he's Marco Pierre White and here's my
take on his top ten rules of success and
as always guides as you're watching the
videos if you hear something that really
resonates with you please leave it down
the comments below and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired as
well also as you are writing something
down it's much more likely to stick in
your head to enjoy
my head chef Robert Reid said to me says
where to go from here
knocking and I said to him when I was a
young boy mister you read you so tell me
about a restaurant in Paris called Plaza
which was the ultimate because it had
three stars in Mission and five red
knives and forks I said we've got three
stars with four black knives and forks
let's go for five red knives and forks
the next three years we pushed and we
pushed and we pushed and we did
everything in January 1980 we went our
three stars with five red knives and
forks I'd realize my dream all those
years later and that dream I had when I
was 17 years old I was now 37 years old
so for 20 years I'd worked to realize my
dream things don't happen overnight you
have to make the emotional and a
personal investment to make your dreams
come true
many people have condemns me for being
controversial
I was never controversial as I've always
said
most of my reputation the product of
exaggeration and ignorance did I shout
if I did I lead from the front I nailed
my color to the mask I fought for my
profession he'll be a rebel make sure
you win it'll be revolutionary
then fight what you truly believe in and
that's all I ever did and the boys
behind me they followed me my father
sent me to her ago which was a star town
and told me to find a job the most
daunting task in my life I went to
Harrogate and I found a job at the hotel
to George in Harrogate and I started
that on the 20th March 1978 it wasn't
great food but what they taught me
with how to push how to run how to be
consistent because consistency is born
out of discipline how never to be late
how to go to work when you're not
feeling well and let the chef send you
home success is born out of luck
it's awareness of mind that takes
advantage of that opportunity
you will all be confronted with
opportunity you must take advantage of
it because if you don't take advantage
of your opportunity you'll never realize
your dreams whether you want them or not
is to be relevant you don't know that
until you achieve it I think what gave
me the drive to succeed was my
insecurities reading writing struggling
it gave me that individual drive to
prove myself because I'd been belittled
at school I'd never been taken serious
as always looked upon as being a fool
being stupid so it was to fuel behind me
and that's what made me work far harder
was to prove to my father and other
individuals including several teachers
but you know maybe I struggle with
reading and writing but I had and
possess other great qualities so had I
been dealt with as a child I may never
have the energy or the fuel to drive me
to get to where I got I'm not a
celebrity I'm not talented I'm no one
special I'm like everybody else in this
world what I crave his ordinary which I
said to earlier is I come to work I do
my job and my job today really if I'm
honest is inspiring the young like
having the case in students
commended him in this afternoon and show
me respect and kindness and I only hope
that my stories that my philosophies and
my tours inspire them the last thing I
said to me today
if the story is more important than a
recipe a recipe can confuse you the
story can inspire you when I was a young
boy I had that privilege of working with
people like the great Michael Lewis on
the Box Street the great owners of the
boxing mr. eager mr. long can lamda
Baker al-bari Pierre Kaufmann Euclid and
it's the great Roman blonde but what did
he really teach me without sells
tourists how to inspire people that's
what's important I've had lots of bad
luck in my life but I think having bad
luck is equally as important because
when you have bad luck in life you have
to reflect you have to take the
knowledge from that experience we've all
been treated badly we've all made
mistakes we've all had bad luck so what
we have to do is reflect take the
knowledge from that experts and then
allow it to enrich our life it's as
simple as that
let's be honest even people say jabbing
regrets Marco I say no because I did not
be for all those mistakes I made
I won't I won't have the knowledge that
I have today I won't have the experience
that I have today because mistakes are
fine as long as you take the knowledge
from a mistake and so the one thing
might funnel the Gately which was really
key was that work ethic that ability to
get myself up in the morning no matter
how tight I was to push myself to those
pain barriers and again the combination
of the loss of a mother at six and then
being sent out to work at ten we
starting work at five o'clock in the
morning through the mill ground being
dropped off at 8:45 at school in the
milkman you their work ethic so that
combination of those two work ethic and
great insecurity was what got me to
where I went to I turned my dream into
reality
but sometimes reality is not what you
think it is winning three stars was the
most exciting journey of my life then
the day comes where you're king of your
world and people views of use now change
because you're up there and you have to
play a systematic game it's a formula
you just roll out the same dishes day in
day out and then you know I sat down one
day and thought to myself do I really
want to do this anymore
it's not pleasurable and so I sat down I
talked to myself or my options my first
option was to continue working six days
a week between 18 100 hours a week my
second option the level I pretend I cook
when I don't cook my third option was to
pluck up the courage from within to give
back myself to abdicate from my position
to accept that to mode I'm unemployed
I have no status for what do I have I
have an opportunity discover myself as a
person and to let go of everything that
I've ever worked for
let go of my status to walk away from my
dream the very tough decision and one
day little thought just written into my
mind and that little thought was that I
am being judged by people who have less
knowledge than me so what does it all
work very little
[Music]
so that's what gave me the courage to
walk away honestly I have to fight the
ego every day
the ego major is the most extraordinary
part of it because when we think we've
suppressed it and we've beaten it it
manifests itself into another form and
another shape and starting over again
and so every day you have to fight the
ego and allow the humility to come
through in my opinion Crudup and by
allowing humility to come through
because let's be honest success which
you want to speak about is borne out of
arrogance people thinking they're good
but greatness comes from humility and
being successful is not good enough it's
all about being great and what are we
doing life you can have the most humble
job in the world but you can be truly
great you can be a humble girl or I'm
going to be you can be a great person
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because in Atkins asked
me to so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
it down in the comments below and I'll
see what I can do
I'd also love to know what did Marco say
that had the biggest impact on you and
why what did you learn from this video
that you're going to immediately apply
to your life or to your business leave
in the comments and I'll see what I can
do finally I want to give a quick shout
out to Anastasia zinchenko thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
gear one word and making that awesome
YouTube video on it as well I really
really really appreciate your support
believe in yourself believe in your
abilities and believe in your future so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is let's love
I'll see you soon